there is a lady is a lady not Lady Gaga
called Anna Anna Anna hey Anna
she's made oh no no no you're alright
actually they're really sweet they're
really sweet she's made loads of these
little miniature versions of your
outfits so like that's the famous one of
you there's another famous one thank you
so much there you are there's a little
Philip Treacy head Kenny no that's
Alexander McQueen right there on the
right
this one yeah they all really gonna need
some help with those Dolly's we have
that one on a picture with picture the
real one of that one see look how good
it is aren't they good well done Anna
new Claire
until they give her a kiss okay come get
a kid
[Applause]
they appreciate I know that took a lot
of time so thank you
[Applause]
I like that there's no heads yes this is
just packaging sorry
[Applause]
that's a part of my head what's this
spinning oh I an ax I missed I can smell
this from here
[Applause]
we can put in the paella to cheer it up
it really is not that fresh oh it's very
nice thank you
the real neat dress I just assumed you
kind of cooked it but you it's being
preserved in some strange way been
jerked
[Music]